battu par le démocrate joe biden le 3
novembre lors de la présidentielle
donald trump doit quitter la maison
blanche le 20 janvier
mais après des violences au capitole du
6 janvier l'actuel chef d'état est sous
la menace d'une procédure d' impeachment
en raison notamment du 25e amendement de
la constitution américaine adoptée en
février 1967
cet amendement permet de démettre à
président de ses fonctions en le
déclarant inapte c'est ensuite le vice
président qui prend sa place à la tête
du pays le vice-président et une
majorité de son cabinet peuvent demander
l'application du 25e amendement par une
déclaration écrite qui sera ensuite
transmise au président du sénat et de la
chambre des représentants le président
lui-même peut aussi invoquer cet
amendement s'il ne se sent plus en
mesure d'assurer ses fonctions pour une
durée déterminée
jamais le 25e amendement n'a été
utilisée dans l'histoire des états unis
la destitution de donald trump serait
donc inédite
outre son départ de la maison blanche
donald trump pourrait dire adieu à sa
carrière politique
si la procédure allait à son terme son
rêve de réélection en 2024 deviendrait
impossible
l'inpi schwint rendant un président
inéligible à vie